مهام القنص من الجو لا تنتهي وتتم في مسرح
عمليات معقد في منطقه دوناتسك في هذه
المره لم يكن مجرد استطلاع لحركه الجنود
الروس بل لمهاجمتهم بالقذائف في خناقهم
يستخدم في توجيه قذائف المدفعيه ضد اهداف
متحركه للقوات الروسيه
يبحث عن صيد ثمين بعد ان امست الاشتباكات
في باخمه اقرب الى حرب شوارع على بعد مئات
الامتار لكلا القوتين المتقاتلين
بروزوين من وحده القناصه في الجيش
الاوكراني يؤكد ان اصوات طلقات بنادقهم
الخاصه والمتطوره تثير الرعب في قلوب جنود
الخصم
بالنسبه للبروزويين يجب على القناص الا
يقترب كثيرا من منطقه الاشتباك حتى لا
يكون مرئيا
بضع مئات من الامتار كافيه برايه لاصابه
الهدف
وجوده القناصه في معارك الشوارع فعال
للغايه خاصه عندما تريد الاستيلاء على
نقطه بعينها وتتحرك بشكل صادم للعدو
اعتبرت المعارك في باخمه خلال شهورها
التسعه عددا من اصناف الاسلحه الارضيه
والجويه كاسفيار وطريقها الذي يربطها بباخ
من الغرب يجعلها هدفا للقصف الروسي على
مدار الساعه
ومع ذلك تستمر الامدادات في الوصول الى
الخطوط الاماميه للجبهه شكلت باثمته وما
تزال براي قاده عسكريين اوكرانيين جبهه
استنزاف مؤلمه لروسيا عبر تعطيل تحقيق
اهداف الحرب المعلنه وهي فرض السياده
الكامله على دنباس حسن الشوبك الجزيره غرب
اخمت شرقيه اوكرانيا